We Stand we fight and we will win
because we are united Ukraine America
and the entire free world
I thought his appearance was powerful I
thought his message was compelling
um I felt it was inspirational it was
convincing it was skillful
um and it was superbly delivered we
should remember that he was an act he
knows how to do this just as Ronald
Reagan was the great communicator
zielinski is as well very very important
allusions to the Battle of the Bulge to
Saratoga the turning point of the
Revolutionary War to Churchill to FDR to
um
mentioning planes and and the Patriots
and artillery and tanks and all of this
uh and then of course ending with this
really moving uh presentation of a flag
a Ukrainian flag from the battlefield in
bakmut where he was the day before when
he was presenting Awards to those on the
front lines and by the way that day
President Putin was presenting Awards to
his buddies in the Kremlin and and other
leaders not on the front lines your
support is crucial not just to stand in
such fight but to get to the turning
point to win on the battlefield
we have artillery yes
thank you
we have it is it enough honestly not
really
he's not just acting uh he's using all
of his acting skills
in a very impressive manner but also I
think absolutely sincerely you can't
fake this you know it we used to
occasionally observe about leaders
um in combat and so forth that you know
if they they don't really love soldiers
they can't fake it forever
um sooner or later it's very evident
whether someone is truly sincere or not
and I think there is no question
whatsoever about his sincerity it
enabled his sincerity to come through in
an even more compelling and Powerful
manner in the same way that I think
Ronald Reagan was enabled by his acting
career to very sincerely and powerfully
convey particularly important points
during the final years of the Cold War
that in large measure was brought to an
end because of the efforts in his
administration and then the one that
followed George H.W bush certainly the
culmination of leaders of both parties
efforts but very powerfully carried
through by Ronald Reagan
so again I think a very very important
trip to his first trip outside Ukraine
since the invasion began
and both symbolically and substantially
important again to the country that more
than all the others put together has
enabled him and his forces to defend his
country and on at a moment when in the
senate in particular there is the 1.7 or
8 trillion dollar Omnibus spending bill
that it concludes 45 billion of various
forms of assistance for Ukraine which
would carry that effort all the way
through probably the bulk of 2023. so
very important to get that done during
the lame duck portion of this particular
Congress before the the shift in the
house when it could get much more
difficult
foreign